تحدث نيك روبرتسون من سي إن إن إلى
المتحدث باسم طالبان يوم الأحد حول أولويات المجموعة في
الوقت الحالي وإلى أين تسير الأمور
من هنا
أولويتنا هي الحفاظ على الأمن
ومن ثم
سيكون لدينا
حكومة جديدة على حكومة أرغان شاملة
إسلامية في الأيام المقبلة
أشخاص ليسوا أعضاء.  من
طالبان ليكونوا جزءًا من هذه الحكومة الجديدة ،
نعم ، كنا نعتزم ذلك
لأننا عندما نشهد
حكومة أفغانية إسلامية شاملة ،
فهذا يعني أن هناك حكومات
أخرى تشارك أيضًا
في الحكومة بحيث تجعلها
حكومة إسلامية شاملة
الحكومة هل
ستطالبون الجيش الأفغاني الحالي بالقدوم والانضمام
إلى قواتكم لتوفير الأمن في
البلاد
لمن يسلمون
أسلحتهم وأه ينضمون إلى قواتنا
ويتم
منحهم العرق وحياتهم في
الممتلكات يتم تأمينها
ثانياً أسمائهم  تم تسجيلهم في
سجلنا ، لذا فهم
نوعًا ما في قوة احتياطية
وفي الوقت المناسب سيتم استدعاؤهم
باسم  هناك حاجة
لأشخاص وأنا من
بينهم أطرح أسئلة حول
تعليم الفتيات ، كان هذا أحد الأشياء
التي جعلت الإدارة الأمريكية
قضية مهمة في أفغانستان
وأحد الأشياء التي ترغب
في اعتبارها إرثًا للبلد
حيث تفعل  طالبان يقفون في
طريقهم للمضي قدمًا الآن ،
أنت ستدير البلد ،
ماذا ستفعل بشأن تعليم الفتيات ،
هل سيتمكنون من البقاء في
المدرسة بعد 12 إلى 18 عامًا ، هل سيكونون
قادرين على الذهاب  إلى الجامعة ، نعم
حول أن سياستنا واضحة
وأن
النساء يمكنهن مواصلة تعليمهن من
المرحلة الابتدائية
إلى التعليم العالي ، ما الذي
تفهمه على أنه سبب
نجاح هجومك العسكري لدرجة
أنه فوجئ الجميع ،
هل فوجئت كيف
سارت الأمور بسرعة ولماذا تعتقد أنها كانت ناجحة جدًا
لأن لدينا جذور بين الناس
لأنها كانت انتفاضة شعبية
للشعب لأننا كنا نعرف ذلك
ودبلوماسيًا  المواطنون الأجانب
والصحفيون في أفغانستان ،
ما هي السياسة المتبعة
لهم لمواصلة
عملهم ، حيث
يجب أن تظل السفارات
تعمل ،
فنحن ملتزمون بتوفير
بيئة آمنة لهم
وأيضًا ليس فقط للدبلوماسيين
والسفارات ولكن أيضًا للمنظمات غير
الحكومية الدولية.
إجراء محادثات مع
الأمريكيين حول هذا
الرحيل الدبلوماسي في المطار
أولاً وقبل كل شيء
نسميه أميركيًا
لا يجب أن نستيقظ مع السفارة
لأننا قلنا
إننا لن نستهدف السفارات
ولكننا سنوفر بيئة آمنة
لعملهم ،
لذلك عندما يكون الأمريكيون عندما  أنت تقول
للأمريكيين أنه يجب عليهم البقاء
والبقاء في السفارة وهم
يغادرون.
كيف تفسر ذلك هل
تفسر ذلك لأنهم لا يثقون
بك
يجب أن يثقوا بنا